when I think of great songwriters and
people who write lyrics I think my
self-consciousness would get in the way
in other words do you ever sit there and
go oh [ __ ] I don't know if this song is
trite or not are people gonna laugh at
me or are they gonna take it seriously
and really get off on this I would be in
a panic I remember the especially
feeling that way on the the second
record because the first record you just
kind of wrote it was your you know I'd
been writing songs and you know on my
own and making Demos in this little
apartment and being in you know smaller
bands and and playing clubs and opening
for other fans and and then when the
Seattle
fellas invited me up and now we were
even though we were making like a real
record in my my first real record and
and uh I was so glad they had faith in
me but really I was writing you know a
lot of stuff was coming out and and it
was happening quick and these were like
the best musicians I had ever worked
with but after that record actually did
well and now when we were making the
second record and then you kind of had
an idea that a bunch of people are gonna
hear it compared to the first one you
know the first one we were maybe
for some reason in my head there was
this goal if you sold 40 000 records you
could they'd allow you to make another
you know that was like the the number we
had to hit you know like you know
Electoral College votes we needed you
know 40 000 records and then we got to
that point and then it kind of kept
going and going so by the time the
second record came on you kind of knew
there was an audience there and and
that's when I felt a little pressure as
to you know could I say this or what
would people think about me or what they
think it was about me where you know
before I wasn't you know I I felt much
more and isn't that right but it didn't
last that long that second album the
pressure to sell albums and to be and
not to just be a one hit wonder it's
just insane the pressure I don't think
people understand it you don't want to
disappoint the band you don't want to
disappoint the record company it's uh
it's tough yeah it's a good problem to
have you know it it uh you know and
looking back on some of those times I I
wish I would have handled a few things
differently you know if I
you know I think if I just would have
known back then that you know it's gonna
be okay you know like enjoy the ride
it's a [ __ ] roller coaster and and
even though the the thing that comes
over your shoulders even though that's
broken
you could you know you're gonna if
someone told me
kind of enjoy it you know like it's
gonna be okay
um that would have been a lot more fun
but I just didn't know that in fact my
instincts were saying like you know
this is not okay and and
you know what's happening you know we
got in a band to to kind of Be Our Own
Boss and and be a gang and and make our
own decisions and and then it felt like
we were kind of you know and these were
good people you know they were working
hard for our record I mean it was nice
of them to do that and and
but there was you know it was really
moving quick for us and
um
and I admit it was a little hard to
handle but I I think that was because we
were coming at it as real people you
know what's funny with us meaning you
and me
I go on the air all the time and say the
greatest Pearl Jam song of all time
glorified G
and I play it all the time on the show
you hate that song like you [ __ ] hate
it you don't like performing it I'm like
how could there be such a disconnect
between us me and you it's crazy I love
that song it's not that I did I say that
I hate that song you were doing this
live uh in San Diego
and you you even sing that you go a
glorified version of a song I hate but
listen to the opening here
there it is glorified version of I hate
this song okay that's just what's
happening what's happening there is I
think that's probably later in the set
right uh I was probably in San Diego
probably hung out with my brothers the
night before maybe how to surf and then
you know we hung out and and then it
sounds like my voice is struggling
slightly there and that song is a pain
in the ass to sing with nothing personal
about it it was just that night
see that makes more sense is that why
you avoid the song though I know that
you guys don't do that a lot in concert
is because it's hard for you to sing
that in a live show no I I in in the end
they're all they all take a bit of
effort but
um you know I I think you know nowadays
you know the last few years we're
getting older but the saw the shows are
getting longer
oh